Let's look at the solution to our history predictor quiz. In c a loop exits
at the beginning. So the first loop will do something like initialize i to zero.
If i is equal to 8. Jump to done otherwise do everything that is need for
intraitation of the outer loop. And then, branch back here.
The inner loop, we'll just do j equals zero. And
then if j is equal to eight, go to sum label D1. Do something,
jump back here. And the label D1 would really be here,
after which we're going like this. So how many entries do we need?
We need at least one entry per branch. Although in fact we need on entry for
each instruction but at least we need to have entries for branches. So
we have a branch that does this here. We have a branch that does this here.
We have a loop back branch here and we have a loop back branch here so
we are talking about at least four entries. In reality we need many many more.
In order to do well on all four of these branches,
we need to see what is the longest history that any one of them will have.
The loop branch is always taken so, really, we don't need the history for it.
Even a single 2-bit counter will do well on these two.
But this one will be testing eight times, for zero through seven.
And stay in the loop and then the ninth time it tests it jumps out. So
really it has a pattern of length nine which means we need an 8 bit history.
With an 8-bit history, we need two to the eighth two bit counters. So
that leads to 256 2-bit counters. Now, what is the pattern of this branch here.
It really is eight times it's not taken, followed by a taken, and that repeats.
The inner branch does exactly the same thing, except it does it many more times.
So, if you look at how many possible patterns we actually have, of length eight.
We have a pattern of eight no takens. We have seven no takens
followed by a taken. We have a pattern of six no taken, then taken no taken,
ect. So we're really using only nine of these two big counters, which again,
shows that. A predictor of this type with a very long history,
will waste a lot of it's many, many entries.